today we're talking about explainable ai
an easier way to find products and a
biopharma breakthrough powered by ai i'm
debbie cabrera and welcome to this week
in cloud where we serve you the lowest
latency
news explainable ai or xai helps you
understand and interpret how your
machine learning models make decisions
we're excited to announce that bigquery
explainable ai is now generally
available bigquery is the data warehouse
that supports explainable ai in the most
comprehensive way with regards to both
xai methodology and model types all done
at bigquery scale enabling millions of
explanations within seconds with a
single sql query
we created a new all products page to
help you easily navigate to your
favorite google cloud products this page
showcases all of the google cloud
products as well as our key part
research organizations the ability in
vertex ai to run deepmind's
groundbreaking protein structure
prediction system alpha fold this is
exciting news for us but game changing
for data scientists and organizations of
all types in the biopharma space from
those developing treatments for diseases
to those creating new synthetic bio
materials
if you want to read more about these
announcements or see a full list check
out the link any thoughts or ideas leave
us a comment or tweet us we'll see you
in the cloud